nous allons passer à l'étranger mais
c'est à la frontière de l'étranger et de
l'intérieur car ce qu'a dit shimon peres
le premier ministre d'israël est
important puisque en effet il a annoncé
que d'ici une dizaine de jours à peu
près la totalité des prisonniers chiites
libanais qui se trouve à la prison date
lite devrait être libérée c'est donc une
lueur d'espoir pour les otages français
tels que jean paul kauffmann michel
seurat marcel carton et marcel fontaine
c'est dans cette ancienne prison
forteresse date lite au sud de haïfa que
sont détenus les derniers prisonniers
chi capturé par l'armée israélienne au
cours d'opérations de ratissage au sud
liban
ces prisonniers étaient devenus monnaie
d échange des otages du boeing de la tbw
a à plusieurs reprises israël avait
libéré par petits groupes près de 800
shit year shimon peres le premier
ministre israélien a annoncé la
libération totale des derniers détenus
d'appli le dernier chiites datent lite
seront qu'il relâchait parle quelques
jours par semaine
dix jours ça va mal et de fait cette
libération de la centaine de chiites
emprisonné encore à athlètes pourraient
débloquer la situation à propos des
otages encore détenus au liban et
surtout la libération peut être des
quatre français jean paul kauffmann
michel seurat marcel fontaine et marcel
carton car nabih berri le leader chiite
a toujours posé comme conditions à la
libération de ces otages la remise en
liberté de tous les détenus
un espoir que partage mme adam kaufman
elle seule promesse qui nous étaient
faites pour jean paul et michel c'était
après la libération des otages était w à
les ravisseurs ont dit on libérera
kochman y sera quant aux derniers
prisonniers ta titre sortira et cette
promesse n'a été encore répété la
semaine dernière j'ai vu très longuement
le docteur béraud qui était de passage
en france et qui le second du mouvement
amal et qui m'a dit à chaque fois que
nous avons contacté ravisseurs à chaque
fois ils nous disent kaufmann et sera
sortiront aviez dernier précise atik
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes plein
d'espoir bien sûr nous sommes pleins
d'espoir on a toujours dit qu'on voulait
pas si vrai ce marchandage d'otages mais
malgré tout c'était notre espoir le plus
proche c'est en tout cas celui là et si
ça ne se fait pas c'est que je crois
qu'il faut on peut plus avoir confiance
du tout dans ce que disent et les
ravisseurs le mouvement amal